a raise of hands of how many hey not yet
actually identify yourselves as like a
worrywart oh not really talk about
anything anxiety often I mean I get
anxiety you end up like thinking about
the future a lot and you know I
definitely think by the future a lot and
like that always makes me feel uneasy
get hype i'ma have a cond react about
like if I get a cut or something I'm
like it's definitely affecting my my
lose my arm yes but I know normally like
that's a quick bleep I got kept
affective lose my home alarm but unless
something happens like an insight again
breathing but like normally I'm a worry
worried about [ __ ] that doesn't matter
so like I really want the new the new
Chevy Tahoe and I'm like oh but then so
I want the z71 guys to offer package but
it's only a 5.3 liter right now I don't
want the 6.2 liter for more horsepower
and I get really worried a lot anxiety
thinking about that but you won't be
able to get it this is about choices
yeah about choices I do you want to get
the chicken sandwich or the hamburger
and then you're like [ __ ] and I know and
that seems like a huge decision but
other [ __ ] doubt like I don't know
savings whatever I'm like okay little
things on my stress not a little [ __ ]
you can't control like you don't worry
about things like things that you just
are out of your control like for example
like a meteor landing on earth or even
things like that dude like the
Illuminati's depopulation plan yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah nah I don't care buddy
that's tough that's good that means you
probably just have a lot of mental
strength I just get anxiety over the
small things 6.3 liter I think all right
well here I have I have three tips on
how you can actually two tips on how you
can try to like calm yourself and like
really
psychologically try to gain control over
your exact
you know help me if you if you tend to
be a worrywart so number one is you need
to work towards developing a realistic
sense of control so um for example like
they're saying here how you can control
how I catching your marketing ads are
but you can't control whether people buy
your product so a lot of people end up
stressing over things that you just
can't control so you have to get like a
realistic sense of okay these are things
that are in my lane that I can do and I
can change and I can like I can do
something about but other things like
for example like the current state of
the pandemic a lot of people have been
getting a lot of anxiety and stress over
it because you just feel like holy [ __ ]
what's happening the world's ending and
I can't do anything about it
but they're just saying here like
alright well just you know whatever is
within your control you can tackle I
bought some clothes sticks for our house
just because I was like oh [ __ ] the
world might end and then we might not
have batteries I want a rave the
merchants cut turn bar in the middle
zombie apocalypse lighting and they're
frequently used in the military and you
know I got my handcuffs you suppose I
take up room in the freezer
no I'm whipped I handcuffs not go in the
freezer no the glow sticks you don't put
them in the freezer
no but I was like freaking out if I
should get the yellow ones or the green
ones coming damn it somebody got damn
choices well the green ones are more fun
and I'm probably stressing watching talk
about myself like trying to [ __ ]
answer emails and do all this [ __ ] in
this fulls like that's the other or
green he's like I'm working cuz they
come on a pack of 20 no really not
commit if there was a assortment pack
that what I got it
they're like that red blue white an
assortment pack not on Amazon I can't
pink is cool too
so wait you forgot how much they'll
caught the price wise I mean that just
sounds like it's part of the emerg gets
never expensive it's part of the
emergency you can't have like excess
yeah I don't have forty glowsticks
read the reviews on the green ones
versus the yellow ones
hey how I get Bart because like I'd do
the same [ __ ] but then I just buy
everything I like I'll I don't want to
make the decision and be wrong so I'll
just get both that's what I do for
everything the restaurants on post meats
not sure if I like it
5:17 yeah one of which has to be good
yeah works most of the time yeah I do
that it's like you have a higher upfront
investment could within down the road
now you know this was the right one to
see I'm not crazy
sometimes I'll buy more things and then
I'll just return the ones I don't want
but the problem is I don't have a good
return I don't return a mess tons I
don't even want I can't even if it's
come from about that clock that you guys
have yeah twice they weren't the first
time I was like maybe just faulty about
another one didn't work and I was just
like she was I'm retired I was like she
got a print pull the tab out of this
side or something I don't know what it
is and then every time I come here it
works again and I'm just like black
racist
I bought batteries for that we're wrong
and then I have batteries for a device
that doesn't even need those batteries
and I didn't take them back you can't
throw them away yeah just the right I'm
like well maybe I'll get a device that
needs these bad as one day I'll be
orders men cowboy blood for sure
I do have order blood I have hoarders
but only limited to my closet you can't
afford out see my wife won't even let me
do it happens to be the laundry room too
I have to go through his office to get
to the laundry room yeah she has no
reason to have to go into my office I
gave her her own whole office to shoot
with lights everything she wants
I gave him his whole office so you
better keep it clean there's certain
things you just can't control you know
you just want somewhere to go in love
bar I'm a new desk just so I didn't have
to deal with all the clutter of the old
desk be mad [ __ ] sucks
you really what do you really know she
gives me all kinds of my own space I
think that parts austin i think she
can't control it don't think she gives
it i think you take it just learn it's
gonna run i got all kinds of cool [ __ ]
at home I can't control it
what do you get to put your stuff so I
have in the garage I have a camping
shelf all kinds of championship in a
huge-ass house and then I have another
shelf full of all gun [ __ ] I have a gun
safe they also have a workbench you
found a way to buy two separate houses
and put them into work yes you put your
car there too no I keep my kind of
driveway for you oh you the car could
fit yeah because I keep the [ __ ]
garage [ __ ] clean it's just a great
job of cleaning it but she was gonna
control him in that house she would need
checkpoints you just doesn't know how I
[ __ ] control him that's the thing
that's inception ma'am
but all my I got all the stuff that I
need purchasing there play music you
know goes into one room it's type of
being like she has to give him food and
then she goes to the nether of heart
exactly chickens down with your burger
both yeah into her corner it just keeps
it in like that she's like people know
how many kids you have she's like three
once 3713 in the trash we all have a kid
- his name is Jo Jo Jo cow
we raise 100 you gotten for the weekend
great who's watching them right now yeah
I know buddy I get a lot of lemons for
us though yeah he's real busy with that
yeah see as you were doing that on my
glass Joe coming all right uh second
piece of advice here is for you to
schedule time to worry - you're worried
session no yeah so surely these are for
people 24/7 are constantly worrying and
look to the point where it's like
debilitating so this trick here is to
actually put it into your schedule set
aside 15 minutes every day on the same
hour whatever sits like team and the
worry time is cutting into my meditation
time we have seven minutes left my worry
table anytime you feel the worry coming
up you're like oh hold on I gotta save
it for the scheduled worried hey baby
I'm on post majora that's my worry don't
worry
you got a I still try to like multitask
and like worry while I'm on the
treadmill so I kind of do do that with
so I have a schedule and I'm only a lot
about allowed to worry about that being
during that time so like if I'm doing JK
stuff I worry about like our feature
film JK news and all that stuff and I
don't think about barb or anything I
want another family
JK doesn't exist have another family in
the family
I don't care about work or anything like
any everything could burn down I don't
give a [ __ ] what's the prayer what's the
PI of the worry you trying to think you
trying to get him into fury what do you
think is the wrong answer
so basically the whole day he doesn't
have a family until like 8 o'clock yeah
not anymore this is the hall it's
majority of the day oh there you go so
the only worry about JK on JK days they
don't have hours like if I'm meeting
with Gela or whatever it's like oh I
just break it down like like school like
first period so I can put it there and
then and then that way I don't focus on
other things also probably get worried
so I school okay right now it's only
this time you're always sending me
pictures of dumb [ __ ]
during those out that's his free time
messing that worry time we'll also have
a TV so help break yeah I'm liking you
stop texting me like I'm really focused
right now yeah do the more focused I am
the more done [ __ ] unless end you well
on his schedule he's supposed to send
you dumb [ __ ] more minutes later used to
it yeah I mean at least you worried cuz
for me anytime I feel a sense of worry
I'm like no no not right now not right
now but I don't actually schedule time
to worry about the things I'm just like
just not now he'll we sweep it under the
rug away I'm good I'm good no no it'll
never catch up with you never never go
it's not like a bottling up suppose I
don't even know I'm worrying I'm just in
the kitchen and have it moved for like
45 minutes and then Steve shakes me out
of it I'm like all [ __ ] I have stuff to
do she could do like a trance you're
standing there with like a knife and an
uncut honestly yeah I know you get a
glimpse oh now you gonna go to sex so
you get out of that you just she
honestly
or even just me making a noise like
getting out of my computer terrorism
[ __ ] she'll like I'll reset yeah or
maybe you just go like this with the
world of sauces
[Laughter]
my wallet sauces
[Music]
[Music]